hallo ihr Lieben warte mal als ich so
gemacht hat voll gespannt
okay
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute Lemon
Curd rolls das sind ganz fluffige
Hefeteige mit einer Zitronencreme also
super erfrischend ich habe jetzt hier
direkt meine Schüssel und werde jetzt
den Hefeteig hierhin äh zubereiten ich
schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben und nehmen die
nächste Box genau das ist unter dem
Titel die Videobeschreibung einfach
aufmachen und dann könnt ihr euch das
Screenshot und einkaufen gehen bei mir
gebe ich euch aber direkt einen Tipp
nicht alles rein zu tun weil je nachdem
wie groß das Ei ist könnte es sein dass
sie ein bisschen weniger oder auch ein
bisschen mehr braucht so und zum Mehl
gebe ich jetzt ich mache so eine Mulde
und das ist richtig rein Filmen wenn man
das sieht so so eine Mode bilden und
dann kommt da einmal lauwarme mich
gucken da gebe ich jetzt lauwarme Milch
hinzu die dürfte jetzt auch nicht zu
heiß sein also wirklich nur erwärmen auf
so ca 38 Grad und hinzu kann auch direkt
die frische Hefe wer keine frische Hefe
da hat kein Problem dann könnt ihr auch
trockene Hefe nehmen schreibe ich euch
dann auch in die Infobox wieder die
Mengenangaben sind so direkt dazu einmal
Zucker schöner Nährstoff für die Hefe
gibt aber auch Geschmack ab und das Eier
so quasi alle flüssigen Zutaten das Ei
und die zerlassene Butter kommen noch
mit hinzu und dann fange ich einfach an
zu kneten und gibt nach und nach das
restliche Mehl dazu
[Musik]
den Hefeteig habe ich jetzt erst in der
Schüssel kurz zusammengeknetet und dann
habe ich persönlich mein besseres Gefühl
auf der Arbeitsfläche und sonst habe ich
hier eine feine kleine Kugel geformt und
die wird jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen
Ruhezeit benötigen um einfach aufzugeben
dafür nehmt euch am besten so ein
bisschen Öl ich nehme hier
backtrennspray weil mehr möchte ich
jetzt nicht dazu geben weil das Mehl
verarbeitet sich ja auch beim rufvorgang
in den Teig und dann ist der Teig
eventuell doch so trocken noch ein
bisschen Öl oben drüber und dann
luftdicht verschließen und jetzt 30
Minuten ruhen lassen und dann geht's
weiter mit der leckeren zitronenfüllung
so die Ruhezeit ist vorbei und jetzt
wird der Teig einmal kurz ausgebreitet
ich habe hier meinen ausrollstab 3 mm
sind die Abstandsringe die ich jetzt
hier drauf tue ihr könnt das natürlich
auch nach Augenmaß machen aber wenn man
schon so tolle kleine Helferlein hat
dann muss man die natürlich auch nutzen
so die eine Seite dann auch noch die
andere wenn ihr jetzt eine
Oberfläche habt die wunderbar Antirutsch
ist dann ist es super dann klebt da
nämlich auch nichts an ich habe jetzt
hier sicherheitshalber einfach noch die
Silikon Backmatte unten drunter plus ich
habe jetzt hier auch noch schöne
zentimeterangaben und euch gebe ich ja
auch mal die Zentimeter Angaben an weil
ich weiß nicht wie es ist immer dann zu
Hause sitzt ich hätte gern schon noch
die ein oder andere Info damit mir das
auch gut gelingt wenn z.B haben sie das
Rezept ist nachmachen würde der ist doch
dankbar über jede Information gehört
aber eins zu dem Gedächtnis geblieben
in Bio warst du richtig gut und ich war
richtig schlecht in Bio und habe so soll
ich das erzählt bei der notenbesprechung
ne die die ruft sie jeden einzeln raus
sagt so ja haben sie was was denken Sie
daran
so richtig selbstbewusst alle haben
gesagt super das ist gut das hat Dir
gesagt 4 minus das war alles so was das
kann nicht sein dann haben sie es besser
als wir alle ja hast du schon echt
Unfälle und ich hatte eine zwei bekommen
voll ungerecht ich habe gar keine zwei
verdient um ehrlich zu sein deswegen
[Musik]
aus und dann kommt der Lemon Curd rein
und damit eingeräumt und gebacken
ja
gar nichts mehr zu tun aber ja aber
Roll cool
oder ja ich mich auch gleich auf dem
Tisch gebrochen
danke durchgeben
so das ist nämlich das wunderbare hier
an der Matte und zwar habe ich hier was
haben wir denn hier 28 mal
38 28 x 38 cm habe ich das jetzt hier
ausgerollt auf 3 mm dicke jetzt kommt
Lemon Curd oben drauf und dann wird das
Ganze eingerollt so das Lemon gehört
dass ich jetzt hier benutze das ist
selbst gekauft ist und ich
selbstgemachtes aber ich habe auch ein
Rezept auf meinem Kanal das mache ich
mal ganz gerne wenn ich ganz viel Eigelb
übrig habe dann könnt ihr daraus
wunderbar Lemon Karte zubereiten aber
wie gesagt das hier ist jetzt einfach
ein fertiges gekauft ist und das gebe
ich jetzt einfach auf den Teig streicht
das schön glatt und dann wird das einmal
aufgeräumt
[Musik]
so
einmal den Geruchstest machen das riecht
richtig lecker und das ganze lasse ich
jetzt noch mal 15 Minuten gehen man
sieht eigentlich schon dass der Teig
extrem fluffig ist aber ich mag es noch
einen Tacken fluffiger wenn ihr die Zeit
habt lass es jetzt noch mal 15 Minuten
gehen wenn jetzt Zeitdruck hat könnt ihr
das eigentlich auch sofort in den Ofen
geben wichtig ist dass der Ofen
vorgeheizt ist auf 180 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze und dann brauchen die Lemon
curd-rolls so ca 25 Minuten und on top
mache ich heute noch ein cream cheese
Frosting und das bereiten wir in der
Zwischenzeit zu
[Musik]
so für das Zitronencreme cheese Frosting
brauchen wir
Doppelrahmfrischkäse Puderzucker Lemon
Curd und Vanilleextrakt das sind diese
vier Zutaten die ihr benötigt und ich
finde Vanille und Zitrone matcht immer
sehr sehr gut daher verzichte ich in dem
Fall auch nicht aufs Vanilleextrakt und
das ganze dann einfach nur ganz kurz
verrühren und anschließend im Anschluss
einfach auf die Lemon curdwords geben
[Musik]
so nach dem Backen habe ich ja dann nur
noch das cream cheese Frosting oben
drüber gegeben
ja genau
weitergeben da links ich schwarz oder
rosa ich würde auch gerne rosa nehmen
bitte schön danke
das muss man mit der Hand essen da hat
keine Gabel was verloren einfach
abrupfen und essen das sieht lecker aus
[Applaus]
das ist ein Lemon cream eigentlich
das schmeckt heftig wenn man denkt bei
warmen Temperaturen ist man nicht so der
Hefeteig Fan das ist ein totales
sommerrezept finde ich das geht das
ganze Jahr über aber es ist total
erfrischend ne total Zitrone richtig
zitronisch und fluffig also gar nicht
kompakt oder so und das ging ja auch
echt also es ging auch wirklich schnell
das wird kein Rezept wo Ewigkeiten
braucht lecker
[Musik]
richtig lecker Leute macht es unbedingt
nach eines meiner Top favorite
zitronenrezepte
die Hände wäscht man sich nicht
nacheinander
also was wünschen wir viel Spaß beim
Nachbacken also ich wünsche mir dass ihr
eure Männer oder eure Freunde oder
Mütter oder sonst irgendwas glücklich
macht damit oder schmeckt echt lecker
und sagen bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]